hey guys welcome back to the water lead
podcast the number one rugby podcast on
the planet as voted by me
and as always this episode is brought to
you by the swish platform where you can
donate to a charity while receiving a
personalized video message from one of
your favorite sports stars another huge
week for swoosh last week getting Scott
Barrett on the platform who does join
his brother Bowden and I know how much
everyone loves a Barrett so there it is
the perfect gift idea for anyone in your
family everyone loves the barretts and
just for listening to the water lad you
can get a 15 discount off your order by
using the code what a lad and like I
mentioned up to 70 of the proceeds do go
to Kiwi kids Charities which is such a
great cause it's also super easy to use
and all you'll have to do is click the
link in the description and then go and
choose your star also the great Lair Tim
Bateman has an offer for you that you do
not want to miss listen to this cheers
Jimmy are you looking for an exciting
career for Life After rugby my name's
Tim Bateman and I've been a professional
rugby player for the last 17 years
my plan for Life After rugby was to get
into the well-being and Recovery
industry so I built o Studio New
Zealand's largest wellbeing and Recovery
Center ostudio has given me a career
option where I can take advantage of the
skills I've built through rugby despite
the challenges of covert we've seen
consistent growth in our business and
we've decided to expand o Studio
throughout New Zealand and abroad it's
an exciting time for the well-being
industry and we're looking for top Lads
to be a part of it by opening your own o
Studio
if you're interested hit the
ostudio.co.nz LED to inquire back to the
show
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh what a lead now after the Craig
newbie episode there have been endless
requests to get today's guest on and for
good reason here's a New Zealand Rugby
Legend having performed consistently
well for Canterbury and the Crusaders
which eventually saw him force and sway
into the All Blacks he then moved over
to the UK where he became a God over
there winning back-to-back premierships
with Leicester and on top of all the
rugby accolades he is widely regarded as
one of the greatest Lads ever it is the
great land himself Scott Hamilton
welcome mate thank you very much
pleasure to be here great to have you on
I mentioned earlier about noobs was not
shy of throwing you under the bus with a
few stories on his latest episode and I
think that's got all the listeners very
keen to hear more from the Great Scott
Hamilton I I couldn't think I've got no
idea what he could have said to be
honest yeah you know I thought we had a
great relationship actually I'm actually
going over to see him in a couple of
weeks he's kicking around in Belfast at
the moment so um we're going over there
to catch a bit of uh 2020 cricket
black caps Island so it should be a good
weekend that'll be loose Yeah well yeah
should be we're here Friday Friday
flying out Thursday coming back Sunday
so um you know we're taking the other
half so it'll be will be um
yeah we'll try and be trying
no doubt we'll see one of you on the TV
probably streaking like you I could
imagine you being a big Streaker no mate
I've passed those days for past those
days I actually I've popped up to um
Nottingham to watch day three of the
Test match in um the England England New
Zealand so I was quite good I went with
another kiwi mate we're about two two
rows back from the boundary about third
third man so we got you know we got
pretty close to uh trenty Trent lovely
trenty got a selfie with him on the well
he was uh down there and kiwi mate
brought some um Eskimo lollies and some
chips and kiwi dip and we're feeding up
near Wagner the 12th man of the day and
he was he was flat loving it and the
boys um yeah the boys were loving it was
quite good actually it was quite a good
we uh we did try and sneak into the um
try and get uh into the change room the
maid I was with was trying to claim he
was the um brother of uh Daryl Mitchell
but didn't quite fly with security
oh it's good times but one thing you
probably don't know is that the first um
first few years of my career I was
actually labeled Scott Hamilton
um all the boys used to call me Scott
Hamilton for the first two or three
years of my career after you gave me one
of the biggest don't argues in a quarter
final Tasman versus Canterbury at Jade
Stadium I'm not sure if you remember the
try or the game but I made I feel like
I'm getting to know myself here after I
was called you for so long
oh well it may not to be honest my
memory of games I don't know if that's
because I've had a couple too many
knocks but um I don't remember it you
know individual games at all I've had
I've had interviews with I didn't if
you're over here because Leicester
played Northampton in the semi-final and
the guy was ringing up and asking for
you know can you remember this game and
what happened and I said oh I mate I
honestly you know I know I know where we
finish in a year and things like that
but individual games unless it's a
unless it's something uh that really
stands out I do struggle but
um no unfortunately I don't remember but
I do I actually heard you must have
passed that mental on I can't remember
the um
the other blonde lady
blonde-haired Winger that he ended up
coming over here Denise got um
apparently they were calling the bubbles
that was a long time ago uh what I can't
remember who it was mate I would have
been quick to offload that nickname I
tried to get rid of it straight away
yeah well no it's a weird thing that
nobody calls me it anymore mate over
here no one didn't just didn't catch on
so um
no it's uh quite limited not not so much
not such a Nick game culture really over
here true how did you get that nickname
that question came up heaps
um
it was if I was uh I've got a big head
mate large Cranium which you maybe not
can tell but you know if people try my
uh hats on it I'm it's a nightmare going
hat shopping mate absolute nightmare
I've got a you know they're only a
select few that can fit my Suite so it I
when I started High School I was um
quite small
um sort of in the I think I was like it
when I went to Boyce higher in the third
form I was um probably the fourth or
fifth shortest out of a get out of our
year of like 30.
um I grew obviously in high school but
my uh I I think let's just say I grew
into my head at the time they thought my
head looked like a bubble or somebody
did started and
um yeah it uh it just stuck stuck for
yeah for a long time really there's
still a couple of people that call me
over here you know when you're running
to you don't see them for a while but um
yeah now it's uh yeah it's just mainly
mainly Scott over here mate would not
have predicted that I thought it had a
much bigger story behind it than a big
head well I did I you know it was
something I mean I sometimes if I if I
had a couple of drinks I'll you know the
chat up line could be used you know do
you like blowing bubbles high on bubbles
so um you know that was something that
does that work very often though to be
honest
oh it's good stuff well but you did
mention a little bit about your um time
at schooling pretty Keen to hear a
little bit more about what life was like
for you growing up so I know you grew up
in Christchurch but what's the rest of
your childhood like
um yes I was on a I grew up in a farm in
North Canterbury
um and then went to
um boarding school at the mighty Factory
and yeah I mean it was I was a bit of a
shy lead to be honest
um and didn't really do a lot at school
I um I was young for my year as well as
a unborn in March so I was um sort of
six months behind most most leads and um
I was because I was quite good growing
up you know like the Under 11's and
stuff I made the a teams right through
but I wasn't doing a hell of a lot to be
honest
um just letting you know my second year
that's when Aaron major started school
and I was playing 13 he was playing 12
and
um yeah he was just dominating
absolutely dominating he was just you
know man there was a it was just a man
back then you know and he was uh he was
just kicking out so I still remember him
peeling off a lift for the drop goal
when he was about I think he was either
14 or 15.
um from halfway uh you know stuff like
that he was just he was just
Head and Shoulders above everyone else
and you know you I suppose there are
guys that you see
you know that do dominate but he wasn't
he wasn't big if you know what I mean he
was obviously well built but he wasn't
like a man Mountain that was running
through he just had the skills and um
you know kept passing around and he was
a guy that you could clearly see was
gonna do something uh pretty special and
obviously he did
um but he ended up um so I had a good
good childhood playing rugby for Glenn
mug
um you know kicking around the farm and
then both my brothers went to boarding
school so I followed them there for five
years and
um got to my last year of uh fourth
seventh form last year of school and um
I thought I was gonna get put into the
second 15.
um because I didn't see myself as a
first steam player but they didn't even
put me there they put me in the thirds
which was um a bit of a knockback for me
didn't really want to play there because
the thirds was sort of the the team that
nobody really wanted to play for you
either played first or seconds or you
wanted to play social rugby in the
fourth or the fifth and then but anyway
tried to get out of it wasn't allowed
but subsequently turned out probably be
the best thing that could happen to me
because I am I instead of being a you
know an average player and a good team I
was a good player and an average team
and you know I was playing 10 and
kicking goals and and all of a sudden I
realized that I had to you know I had to
do something if we were going to do all
right because guys were relying on me
whether it's you know I wouldn't hit
Aaron major inside you you didn't have
to worry about too much he he did it all
anyway but all of a sudden you know I
was in an ever like I said in an Everest
team and I was able to stand out and it
gave me a lot of confidence in it you
know something I sort of tell parents
that today you know I think sometimes
kids need to take a step back before
they go forward oh certainly one of
those because people love to see their
kids in the a teams and the top teams
but some late some people don't respond
to that and I certainly you know I was
just happy letting other people do their
thing and I was just looking after my
little piece of grass and and trying to
knock the stuff up but then all of a
sudden yeah like I said it was um it
changed and um gave me a lot of
confidence and I you know if I played
second 15 rugby you know who knows what
would have happened I still would have
probably been doing the same sort of
things and
um and you know I suppose hopefully at
some stage I might have ended up doing
what I was doing but I think that was a
big Turning Point
um and you know it was it was really
good for me so do you have high rugby
aspirations at the time were you
planning to make rugby a profession yeah
okay no no way in the world was I um
even when I saw I left I went to Lincoln
uni
um again just following my Brothers
didn't really know what I wanted to do
just sort of did a marketing degree
because that was the only thing that I
sort of half took my fancy
um and played played for a year for the
not for looking uni but Lincoln Club
they had an under 19 site so played for
them and that just because a lot of my
mates were you know a lot of the uni
boys were playing there but I was always
planning on going back to Glenmark the
year after which I did and I've got a
few LEDs from from Lincoln
um and you know like my brothers did you
know they didn't
um you know have any have any links
anywhere so I've got them out to play
for for Glenmark either and Dove one or
div two
um you know and did that for a few years
and I sort of I can't remember the exact
years but I made the the canterburyans
under 19 so the under 19 bees
um which was good fun with uh Wayne
Burley and Richard low were coaching
um good lads those two
um Richard low great man to have sit
over breakfast before a game he's got
many a story and uh yeah no great man
um and uh you know he's up for my you
know sort of he kicked around Glenmark
for a bit as well but um I didn't really
know him that well but you know he was
yeah good bloke good man and then um I
think
I made it into the Canterbury under 21s
after
um after that but again you know like
Richie McCaw was on that side and I
still remember you know we weren't a
great under 21 side
but Richie was flirting with the
Canterbury NPC team at that time and
and it's a male like when he played for
us we won and when he didn't we lost you
know he was that good even as a seven
you know just not endlessly he's not
running around palming people off and
scoring tries but he just made the brick
breakdown you know they they couldn't do
anything because he's there stealing the
ball and we're looking after our ball
and and you know it's uh yeah sort of an
under his indirect influence on the game
was just massive and um yeah so then
um and then I got what was I playing so
I was playing in the country still so I
was playing for North Canterbury and
Canterbury country and I we we played
again I think I was playing for North
Canterbury I can't remember but we've
played Marlborough and um I did a ride
of them I think I scored a couple tries
and and Marlborough came um knocking on
the door I think it was in in uh Cannery
B at that time just been selected for
Canary B and I went to and I they said
that I was looking for a job you know
I'd finished uni I was trying to work
out what I was going to do and
Marlborough said that they'd give me a
job
um and then I remember Steve Hansen was
coaching Canterbury and he's he got me
in the office and said you know it's not
all about the money and I said yeah I
know but I said you know they're
offering me a job it's a good
opportunity
and he said well what if we offer you
what they're offering you and bearing in
mind it was like five grand or something
like yeah you know annually and that was
all it was but I said oh he goes we'll
just stay and I said yep so they signed
me up in a contract which then and I was
only in the Canterbury B team so like no
one was being paid but when I say being
paid like I said it was you know five
grand but certainly at that time you
know I felt king of the king of the
castle obviously so I stayed and kicked
around playing bees and really enjoyed
it
um again good great bunch of lead the
the Canterbury visas was awesome fun
um and that was a time too I don't know
if they're doing it now but you followed
around the uh the NPC team so you play
curtain razors and you know still be
able to go out with you know stay the
night in Auckland or Wellington or
whatever and come back and um yeah get
probably get all the benefits of uh of
playing NPC obviously not financially
but but um not the pressure was the way
I saw it was a good good year or two in
the beef which was awesome right you
would you would have been peeking off
um some of those traveling trips
overnight stays bees a few beers after
the game yeah mate it was awesome it was
awesome
um yeah I mean not like a Yeti like all
the trips I mean obviously once the you
know when they started totting the belts
and I think the B you know the B
timetable yeah I think again I don't
know what they do now but you know it
sort of went away a little bit um
obviously that's sort of the first thing
that's going to go but um you know I
think old old foxy was uh manager of the
bees when I was there too so um always
stay close to him he had the uh the CR a
few uh credit cards so you could get a
couple of beers on them if you stayed
tight to him which was always a good
good option and then you make you answer
the Canterbury Squad obviously the All
Blacks were still playing NPC back then
so mate what was it like going into that
Squad so what happened was I I went to
America actually so I
um I finished uni I didn't really want a
serious job so I got a job doing what my
my older brother used to do just working
at an auctioneers
um uh there's only a small smaller
company there's like two uh three
full-time people and myself it was sort
of like three quarter time but generally
he'd you know my boss would look after
me and you know try and give me my 40
hours and make sure I got paid and
things like that so
um I did that and then at the end of
that I had to make um who was playing in
California the year before he said you
want to come over
and you know that I was like yep sure so
the club paid for your flights and then
you just stayed we stayed with a
um a couple of fellows in the team
and they go you know we just did a job
like a part-time job
and so effectively just worked to pay
your spending money so we did that for
four months over there which was awesome
really loved it um you know a good bunch
of leads were in the middle of
California
um
and yeah we had a we tagged along to a
stag to stag due to Las Vegas and uh had
an awesome had an awesome trip there as
you can probably imagine I do remember
we um uh battles with the Kiwi followers
with those those I saw I went to America
was just after September 11 too so it
was obviously a bit nasty but we um
we're about to leave and um
the day we were leaving we thought we'd
just have one last look around the place
and then we went past and there was a
casino that was just down from where we
were staying it was offering dollar
drinks so we're like oh we'll just just
have one for the road and then we ended
up doing I don't know nine or ten
um and very quick succession
um having um uh having just sort of
working up really and then um we I don't
know so one of us did something I'm
pretty sure he did something because
I've got a picture of him being uh like
escorted by an armed guard you know with
the weapon drawn out of the casino which
is and then I that was allowed I was
told that we're not allowed to take any
pictures in the casino but I I still got
it at home somewhere actually a great
photo of the of the police with us with
his hand up saying no photos to me but
um yeah we were uh I mean most most most
people sort of uh once they heard from
New Zealand they loved us you know um
Americans tend to love the kiwis
I don't know where I was going with that
where was the question
that's right sorry and then um came back
to
um New Zealand and I wasn't in the best
shape and I missed pre-season just
started playing for Glenmark but I still
felt I was good enough to be in
Canterbury country but then somebody got
injured I can't remember one of the
Wings got injured
and I got called in ended up starting
and we were playing
geez I couldn't even tell you who were
playing we're playing uh it must have
been if it was Cannabis country must
have been otago country or Southland
country we're playing in haranui up in
North Canterbury and um
I played also mate played scored three
tries just everything everything I
touched just turned to Golden
um it was in front of um one of the
Canterbury selectors
and then he went back and then I I was
um so at that time I was living at home
just on the farm and I was I was
actually working for um
uh I'll mention me old boss Jeremy
rockstars I was a sheep daughter so for
all the uh um
um non-agricultural people out there
you're scaring a sheep to work out how
many lambs are in it and then I would
spray them accordingly so whether
they've got no Lambs they've got one
lamb or they've got two or they're gonna
have an early one or a late one and then
obviously that that uh means the farmer
can draft them out and feed them and
look after them separately so I just
stood there
spraying sheep all day
whilst my man scan so I did that for a
while and um he was he had work up up
north in kaikoura and he said oh hey can
you come to kaikoura and I said well
they're naming the Canterbury team soon
um and he goes I sort of need to know so
I remember going in to see um
must have been Aussie McLean I think it
was Aussie McLean I can't remember I
think it might have been Aussie McLean
at that time um
and yeah I asked this and I said I was
really really sorry
um I don't you know I've got work if I'm
selected obviously I can't go because
it'll Clash but if not then obviously
you know my boss needs to know and he
and he just goes you better tell your
boss
um he's gonna have to find someone else
and I was quite I was quite shocked I
genuinely didn't think I was gonna gonna
make it but obviously I need to ask the
question so but bearing in mind this was
a Canterbury team that was without all
its all blacks at that time and at that
time was 2002 so you know that that was
a you know uh Ben Blair Reuben Thorne
you know all the Mages
um
oh yeah the team was we were probably
missing 12 14 players and new blacks
Canterbury side so um
yeah and then play played the first few
games
um all the All Blacks came back
um and I um I understood that you know
there was going to be me going back down
to the bees but you know again I had
such an awesome time at the Beast love
the bees
um so he ended up just going down there
it was you know I I expected it and was
comfortable with the decision and then
um obviously at the end of the year
um Dean's the Crusaders were selected
and again
um I wasn't even playing Canterbury so I
was like there's you know there's no
chance um and it was it was
it was a toss-up probably between me and
um Alicia tupeloy I don't know if you
remember him but
um Ireland Winger who's a big boy he
played some some good stuff for um for
NPC he's a good player and um I you know
I expected him to to be there and again
at the time whoever was selected we were
well down in the in the picking order
with um you know running back uh Ralph
Blair McDonald
um yeah uh there's a couple of others as
well so we were but um and Dean I was
I'd moved into Christchurch at this
stage because um because I made
Canterbury and I was working at the old
um Chris England's um former Canterbury
locks uh woodturning place I'm sure
plenty of rugby boys have been through
that mighty fine establishment to um try
and uh get some work and get some money
together
um so I got a call from Rory Dean saying
do you want to come and have a meeting
and I was like yep sweet and I'd again
had no idea I thought it was just going
to be this is what you need to do mate
we see you got some potential this is a
big off season blah blah blah and you
know I told my um my boss that I had a
meeting and he was joking oh he's going
to tell you in the Crusaders and we all
had a laugh and it was a bit of a giggle
and um
and I sat down in front of things and he
goes um do you want to be in the
Crusaders do you want to be a crusader
he said and I'll win yep and he goes
congratulations and I remember sitting
there thinking
trying to get around because I'm in my
head I'm like [ __ ] he's just told me I'm
in the in the Crusaders and then and he
stood up shook my hand and he said I
couldn't he said I could give mum and
dad a call but you've got to keep it to
yourself and
even you know I called up the old man
and I said I'm in the Crusader's dead
and he goes oh well done he said so um
when are they making the Final Cuts then
and I said no no that's it you know I'm
in the squad of 28. it was it was
phenomenal and it was actually the year
that um there was a year that Ben Blair
um a couple of games after that he
smashed his shoulder so he's out for the
season and then we got Brad thornan on
the interest injury dispensation so it
meant that um we also I went up the
picking order so I ended up playing
quite a few games but again in that
first year but should I felt out of my
depth I hadn't played anywhere near that
level or trained or you know I'm just a
I was just a skinny country boy who
didn't really know what the hell he was
doing so um you know I had had some
awesome players around me um but it was
a bit of a steep learning curve for me
did you feel like you were getting
better really quickly as you're playing
because obviously your growth from the
third 15 to now being in the Crusaders
on the Wang worth surrounded by All
Blacks I think you're the only non-all
back in the side pretty much at the time
so did you feel like you'd developed
quite quickly to be in that position or
like you said were you well out of your
comfort zone
incrementally better every year which I
suppose most people would do probably
say I don't know 14 through 18 but it
sort of happened like 18 through 22 to
me so I was at back end of 22 and I made
the Crusaders so I was I was a little
bit behind anyway but you know in terms
of weights and stuff I was well behind
Whenever there was strength testing I
don't know you're sure you've had plenty
of guys on here that people that died
the bench press they've got a shoulder
injury or something because they don't
want to embarrass themselves I was doing
that as much as I could
um just trying to um uh but yeah once
once I made the Crusaders you know you
get into that routine of
um you know obviously the preseason the
stuff first preseason is tough but you
get into the routine you know at the end
of the day you learn you know you can
only push what you can push you're there
because you're a good rugby player not
because you're a weightlifter and
obviously you've you've got to do it to
get to a standard and I did what I
needed to do but as long as I'm getting
better you know I still I was still even
over here when I came to Lister you know
um Jordy Murphy the orange like he was
the only fella that could it was it was
weaker than me in the in the weight room
but you know he was a bloody awesome
player and played plenty of
Internationals as well so it goes to
shows uh you don't need to throw the big
turn around but
um the probably the best thing for me
was um was the 2003 NPC
because I'd had 2003 my first year of
Super Rugby and the 2003 was World Cup
yes all the All Blacks weren't playing
so again there was a core a core group
of you know that missed out on so he was
playing 10 Scott Robertson I think was
playing eight
um so those two were sort of running the
show and there was a few other core
leads that were that were in the
Crusaders so
um I was playing 15 then as well and I
bet was probably the year that really
helped me
um we had the shield as well for a while
until we lost it to Auckland you know we
had some really good wins at home
um and it was a really fun year we
didn't you know we lost a lot on the
road but I'm trying to remember I just I
know we lost we lost our last last pool
game against Auckland and lost the
shield and that meant we didn't make the
semis either so it was a bit of a
disappointing year but good fun and that
was a really good stepping stone for me
because again it was I was sort of being
looked at to be a not so much a leader
but sort of a leader you know because I
did a Super Rugby experience where
there's a lot of guys that didn't so so
again
um I think I've you know looking back
I've always done better when I was given
a little bit of responsibility and you
obviously we're in a very successful
Crusaders period so what what made that
um side so so good I'll make the
yeah I couldn't believe like sort of the
oh
050605 was the best team I've been in
ever
um you know he had um Rico gear was
ripping it up on the other Wing as well
scoring tries for fun and um I do
remember you know when I first started
because I remember because again I was
really sort of naive I had no idea what
um I remember one one of my first games
for Canterbury I think I kind of
remember it was most of us being
Canterbury merch made a call when I was
at fullback on the Winger and I ran the
wrong line
and afterwards he goes where are you
going and I said oh oh yeah sorry I
thought it was such and such and and
Mertz you know he's a lovely lead and he
you know he would never really chew you
out unless and he goes oh okay and then
you know when I look back you know a
couple of years later I look back and I
always cringe at that moment because I
was like
you know you're playing professional
rugby mate you shouldn't be running
wrong lines you shouldn't be getting
that and that's sort of something I've
always prided myself on knowing exactly
what I should be doing and where I
should be and you know that was I Still
Still cringing it now even you know
doing that but and then when I'm in I
remember thinking right I've made the
Crusaders now you know I'm gonna have to
because I you know like to beer and
liked I like to you know a night out but
um pre-season tour we're in Australia
and sort of I was just sort of sitting
back seeing what the boys are doing and
they were just you know ripping in you
know Ralphie and um all those leads and
uh fliny and all that just charging and
I was just oh my God this is awesome
it's just uh pretty much the same as
Kirby B but you get paid a bit more and
you know you're playing better foot of
him
um you know it was it was a real good
social time back then as well and
obviously it was um you know it wasn't
like booze in midweek or anything like
that but once the game was over
generally a Saturday night was a was a
good night damn right
right that's interesting I always
thought it was mainly the Highlanders
obviously noobs talked about a lot of um
his post-match Antics but I always
thought the Crusaders would have been a
little bit more serious and a little bit
less drinking but
um back in that era there was still
plenty of that stuff going on yeah I
mean yeah it was I mean well I mean and
you know I walked into a successful side
as well they'd done really well so
um I mean the guys knew you know when
you were training you train I what I
didn't realize what really was my
opening because I'd only ever been in
the Crusaders environment and then when
I made the junior all blacks and oh
six so five might have been 05 made the
general blacks and we played Australia a
and we did a tour of like Tonga Samoa
Fiji awesome great time
um Ian Foster was coached at that side
actually so um I'd have a bit of
background with him but I'm but yeah
what I've realized is when all the teams
came together is that
you know everyone was sort of somewhere
off the field but once it sort of got on
um to training and just preparation you
could see the Crusaders boys were a bit
different
um just a little bit I don't know just
it's hard to put you I thought I'd have
a little bit more professional that's
the way I saw it anyway yeah and I I
came away from the Gina All Blacks
thinking that's why Crusaders do well
that's why we're so consistent because
our boys have um
I don't know we're just a little bit
more in tune and a little bit more Mouse
about when when it's when it's good to
relax and when it's time to to switch on
and do what you need to do that's
interesting and I I'm talking to a lot
of the guys I think that's pretty
um consistent message across the board
that they just do that extra little bit
um off the field that makes them so
successful so it's interesting to hear
that but you also mentioned
um how surprised you were when you made
the Crusaders geez you must have been
surprised when you made the all black
spot was that like yeah I mean there was
a bit bit of chat I suppose at that
stage because again I was you know we'd
come off the back of 05
which as I said you know I had a really
good Super Rugby season I was um
um I think Leon was out for a couple of
injuries so I cut up a game cat a couple
games of fall back
um I think I generally had started
against oh no Caleb Ralph would have
been playing 13 actually because some I
think he'd moved in from Wing to 13 and
we must do an injury or something had
happened anyway and then so I was having
plenty of game time on the wing and
scored quite a few tries and um
and loved it and then that went fit into
the o5 NPC which we won
um that was The Cannery sword I remember
at the time there's a photo of us like
singing the National Anthem and I at the
time I was the only player not to
represent the All Blacks but obviously
that changed it a year later but you
know you don't really see that now you
know an NPC side that's just got
um 14 or 15 starters of um have pulled
on an all blacktop
um and then
super rugby 06 again we weren't as
dominant o6 but we we still did all
right and that that culminated in the in
the old fog Bowl final against
hurricanes which was a a nightmare for
any fan anyone watching but anyway we
didn't care too much so we um Casey the
last scored I think they only try and
we'd have had a good win and we were
just we're back we're back in the change
room as you do and Deans he goes um or
can I have a word and I was like oh [ __ ]
what have I done I was trying to think
what I've done wrong because I mean why
the hell is he wanting to have a word
with me um
um after we've won I was just I couldn't
you know we went outside and he goes oh
congratulations you're gonna get named
in the All Blacks tomorrow
and I was like oh [ __ ] wow you know
Double Buzz you know we've just won the
Super Rugby title just been told you're
in the All Blacks you know we're we're
probably starting me first or second
beer just thinking and he said right
you've got to be um obvious you've got
to be at Jade Stadium at 10 o'clock in
the morning or whatever and okay that's
cool
um so I did yeah we ended up we had a
good night obviously celebrating and um
and I remember the best part was telling
the old man like afterwards um obviously
again you weren't allowed to tell anyone
but I told the old man at the aftermatch
upstairs and you know it was probably
one of the best best moments of one of
certainly one of the best sporting
moments just seeing his face you know
because it's been yeah as you know your
parents do everything for you travel you
know I had two older brothers they were
forever you know there was only two of
them they all had to get three boys to
three different venues for God no God
knows how many you know winter Saturdays
and probably summer as well with tennis
or Cricket or whatever and you know they
they went everywhere for us so it was um
that was probably yeah it was that was
pretty special
and what was it like going into that all
black camp
um yeah I mean again like so we had a we
had an we had a home Series against
Ireland to start with I don't know if it
was one or two tests I think it might
have been two tests
um I yeah I mean again real sort of
eye-opening I sort of felt like
um I suppose a lot of like when I
started the Crusaders felt like I
couldn't deserved to be there I felt a
little bit awkward
um
yeah and then I was on the bench against
Ireland and was unused
um and which was fine and then there was
this was this would say this was the
height of rotation when we were you know
we were just trotting out and you 15
every week almost and and beaten whoever
the hell we put in front of us um
um so we were playing Ireland somebody
got injured so I got told Roddy are you
going to go to Argentina and you're
gonna start so I've been on the bench
and hadn't played so then we uh the
other 14 starters had nothing to they
weren't even in this Iris test and me
jumped on the plane and went over
and again we I think we went over oh you
know uh 10 days before and the other
boys came say six days so yeah we had a
um did a bit of training because there
were any skeleton coach crew and stuff
like that and but we had a few beers on
that weekend and um I do remember having
a couple of beers with Ellie Williams
that's there and then you know it was
just kind of weird having a few beers
sort of the the week before your test
debut but you know everyone was sort of
doing it and to be honest that was sort
of what had worked for me worked for me
so far so why not carry on
um and then you know we got back did we
trained and I remember it was quite it
was quite nice actually being in
Argentina
for it because you're away from all the
you know the home pressures and um I
don't know your home media and all that
sort of stuff I suppose it was sort of
and in Argentina whilst they are
passionate they're not really a you know
obviously a football nation so um Soccer
Nation
um so yeah it was quite good and then it
was actually it was a bloody close game
as as lots of games in Argentina can be
I think it was Liam I think Liam Oz on
the wing and managed to get a try
actually which was um I can't remember
somebody popped the pass and it bounced
off my knee and I scored and Leon
McDonald got sunburned and we were down
to 14 for I think we're up by must have
been up by six five or six because they
a penalty wasn't good enough for them
and myself and whoever's on the other
Wing um uh might have been Dougie Hill
and actually maybe we were sort of
having to do the back three between us
um and yeah we managed to hold on when I
do I do remember Wayne Smith coming up
afterwards and saying you know a good
job Squad out there with Leon being out
Etc and I just remember thinking
I don't know I just felt really awkward
I'd have never been good one and good at
taking praise and things like that and I
was just thinking you know I'm just sort
of doing my job I'm just trying to do my
best sort of type thing
um but then so yeah I know that was
awesome and then I started against South
Africa in Wellington some uh family and
stuff came up to that which was which
was good we had a good win there
um and then sort of Venice advice who
was who was injured um came back
um and
yeah I remember Graham Henry pulling me
aside and say listen he's coming back um
so you're gonna be you're gonna drop out
of the the three yeah try Nation Squad
so again you know my whole life I mean
she's you know you know good he was so
it was like you know it was hardly I
mean obviously it's disappointing to
fall out but
um you know I was just loving the fact I
was there the best the best part was
actually I was still um because I've
been selected for the squad
um I was still getting paid uh like
because of the contracts or whatever
happened I don't know my agent um said I
used don't worry you said yeah I've
heard you've dropped been dropped out
unlucky but don't worry you're going to
get paid for the whole time you're there
and I was like didn't even think about
it I'm like oh because thinking you know
once you're gone you're gone and I said
what do you mean he said oh because you
you've signed up for this whole time so
I'm I'm uh I had a couple weeks off on
uh with me my misses at the time we were
sitting on a beach in Fiji and I was um
getting paid to be in the All Blacks for
a couple of weeks while I was in Fiji so
it was um they changed the rule after me
so uh I was the last one so um
um yeah but anyway I took it I took it
no doubt about it oh that's it
so did they give you any feedback into
why
um you weren't repacked or what stopped
you from being repacked eventually or
was it the move overseas
um no I mean obviously at that time so
that you're bearing in mind you looked
at that 07 that 07 all black team
um I still think was the best Squad of
30 players or whatever it is you take to
a World Cup you would ever
see you know the guys we had and you
know and looking back clearly the
rotation didn't help because we didn't
we focused on having the best 30 players
rather than the best
you know 15 or 20 and you know it
obviously it affected us at you know
World Cup time but you know we had
um Doug howlet was in the stands wasn't
he um he had Carter and Evans you had
McAllister and major
um citavini rocker Coco Howlett
you know we had two guys in every
position and to be honest
I wasn't good enough mate there's no
doubt about that they're you know you
hear you name me name me someone that
you're putting me in a hit of there's
none of those boys that um listen I was
still you know
um I was enjoying it you know I was in
touch with the guys but uh the all backs
and stuff but you know I I got to a
stage where I was 28
um
Aaron major Hood um who had been
um after the World Cup he'd gone to
Leicester
and he gave me a call and because
Heineken mayor the former Bulls coach
South African fella
um he liked me from my time when we
played you know Super Rugby so he asked
and we were um I think Leicester were
close to the celery cap at the time and
so I don't really know what happened but
he they offered me something and I I was
always going to wait another year I was
always going to do another Super Rugby
season
um and then I woke up one morning to an
email from my agent saying they've yeah
they've agreed to what we wanted and I
all of a sudden I was like oh [ __ ] I'm
off to Lister so I I wasn't expecting I
didn't I thought we were too far too far
apart but obviously I thought obviously
Heineken may have you know he obviously
did what he needed to do to get me there
and um
um you know the first thing I did we
didn't have Google Maps back then I
pulled out the atlas to see where the
hell list it was to be honest I knew
obviously you knew about them knew about
them um
you know because I knew they were bloody
good team and and had success but I had
no idea where the hell the UK it was but
um so yeah then my uh myself and the
fiance at the time
um packed up and headed over here in
November 08
sort of back-to-back Winters which
wasn't much fun
um yeah hated it hated the first sort of
three months we um were playing sort of
ball style rugby as well doing a lot of
Kicking and and I found it really
frustrating
um
but um then it changed then he he Panic
had to leave for personal reasons and
the Aussie coach Meadow kind of took
over we started playing a bit more rugby
and started I started really enjoy we
had an awesome year we um my first year
we won the premiership and made the
final of the Heineken Cup
unfortunately because we'd already won
the Super Rugby and the NPC that year
for Canterbury and the Crusaders and
then we won the premiership and I would
have won would have done all four in a
calendar calendar year if we'd beaten
Leinster but some little punk called
Johnny Sexton at the time that no one
had bloody heard of um kicked us out of
the out of the game and um you know or
it was uh yeah clearly clearly he went
on to have a pretty good career as well
right crazy so what what made Lister so
good
um similar sort of a I mean it was so as
I said really different than Jesus the
Fords have just smashed the hell out of
each other like a training at times
Cocker's wretched cockle is England
coach now he was um Leicester through
and through and he was uh yeah they oh
it was really weird because Canterbury
was you know a bit of a less is more you
know certainly once you get into the
season once you've done your preseason
you can you know it's all about being
fresh for Saturday whether it's over
here you had to train twice yeah we
would do Double Days Tuesday and
Thursday ahead of a game
which I I mean I would always the news
probably what news told you about I used
to love just heading back you know
whenever you do drills I just always hit
to the back of the queue it's all trying
to do as minimum minimum amount of reps
as I possibly could
um you know where there are certain guys
um oh yeah
um because we had quite a big squat that
was always that was always my plan
um and then obviously I I it was quite
funny because whenever you do like
contact stuff a lot of the boys would uh
congregate to me because they knew that
they knew that there would be a fairly
light session if you're in my group and
there's one game that um stood out
obviously um the kickoff when it went to
the Penalty Shootout and I think you're
called up at number four or something
for Leicester to noobs disgust couldn't
believe you were kicking with your size
15 Gilberts so they're touching on the
Gilberts I suppose news brought up for
Gilbert so right here so when when I
left um I left New Zealand so I was
going to be going through America and
they had a 40 kg limit
um and I was okay and and then I was at
the pub the weekend before sort of
saying like up my local pub in Glenmark
and um there was a friend of mine that
I'd went to primary school with and her
she had gone to America with her fella
and her followers overstayed in America
and he then got refused entry and thing
is when like when I told you I went to
America we overstayed by a month and I'm
like oh [ __ ] this is the last thing I
need so I rang up uh you know the agent
and the lady that sorts the flights or
whatever happened so I ended up having
to go via where changed the flight and
put me through Bangkok or whatever
so I went down to a 20 kg limit so all
that I had to cut all my stuff that I
was taking over in half and a lot of
that was my playing books I only took
one Pier over and um I was sponsored by
Nike in New Zealand and I thought oh
[ __ ] I'll come over here surely you know
someone will give me free boots
but it was just you know 2008 the start
of the old economic downturn so no rugby
was the first one on The Chopping board
so only the big boys were getting any
sort of um sponsorship when I was
chipping around and Sam vestey was
wearing Gilbert's and I don't know if
you know Sam but he he um he was playing
he's coaching now at Northampton I think
Northampton Saints but he was a good
lead and he goes oh chick sort you out
with um Gilbert anyway the boots the
boots are ropey but I always thought
they were right because he they filled
me up because you could only probably
get about maybe five or six games out of
them before they um stretched too much
before they became useless so the guy um
so I wore Gilbert's for pretty much the
whole time I was there because I'm a
tight bastard as well but I mean
um you do you play you know because
you're training so much and you're
playing a lot you play and I played 32
games I think in my first year and
you're doing probably six or seven
sessions on field as well it's um you go
through your boots you go through your
boots maybe yes I did have my Gilberts
on and penalty shootout I um noobs are
still gutted that he was uh he was
behind me he was number seven but I was
like mate one is a Ford and he Hey
listen I know he's skillful but he was
never going to be picked here to me it
was all we had four kickers
um we had five really Aaron major but
Aaron Aaron had a um he had something
wrong with his league so he didn't
really want to he didn't really want to
kick
um and this was necessary so um we're we
had three kickers and then um it was
Johnny Murphy an Irish Winger and me and
we we were the sort of two you know at
the end of training we'd be messing
around with the kickers and having a bit
of a crack and yeah we could both kick a
ball but we weren't you know we weren't
regular match kickers or anything like
that so um anyway the kick and Coke
Studio who wants to go and I said I said
I'm happy to mate but just make a
decision and we'll just roll with it and
so he said okay Johnny Goes fourth and
I'm like okay sweet is so um anyway so
I'm watching and then I watched Johnny
Miss
and I'm like oh [ __ ] you know we've just
we've just lost this the Heineken Cup
and um and then their fella sticks up
and I still remember he missed as well
and I remember thinking yes yes and then
I was like yes and I was like oh [ __ ]
I've got a kick now because I sort of
gone from Gone From sort of
psychologically getting myself ready to
kicked and then thinking it's all over
and then all of a sudden uh getting back
up there and because I'd only been there
for a while but I know I know it was it
still said a bit weird but all I could
think of was like if I missed this all
my mates back home are going to give me
so much [ __ ] which is an awful it's a
strange thing to be thinking at the top
of your run-up when you've got um you
know all the boys you've been training
with all year and all the fans in the
stadium and all I could give all I could
give a [ __ ] about was the people and all
the all my key roommates giving me [ __ ]
from missing from the 22 in front but
thankfully mine went over
um and then noobs has went over as well
so all that may just stepped up after
that so we um yeah now we did all right
we did all right we uh it was an awesome
awesome night one of my favorite
probably my yeah one of my favorite
games actually awesome fun and favorite
nights go on whatever
oh we just had a good Buster but I
remember being uh we had a bus trip we
had a few and and I remember thinking
like uh we had a Premiership final the
week after
but I remember thinking you know this is
awesome and we had a few beers on the
bus but most of the boys went home there
was just a core of about five or six of
us that went into town
um but I was you know I was sort of
brought up in the Crusaders where you
you celebrate your wins
um you enjoy it and you uh worry about
worry about next week on Monday don't
worry about you know
um so yeah we ate it there was a good
night good bus trip on the way home I
think news was news was there right next
to me there's no doubt he wouldn't have
um shied away from a beer after a game
like that
and then post um Leicester you end up
going down to Coventry uh what was the
reason behind that move and was that to
sort of transition into the coaching
yeah well I I'd always I'd never really
wanted to get into coaching simply
because
you have no real uh say of what you know
if you're really good you get offered a
job elsewhere if you [ __ ] you get sacked
and you've got to find a job elsewhere
so I had two kids um you know I didn't
really want to be dragging them all
around the country or wherever
um so I was always I was still Keen to
keep playing
um I still I mean in my last year at
tigers I had an operation on my knee in
pre-season that took me out for about
seven months so I wasn't Fit until the
back end of the season
and then they um when I was rehabbing I
got asked to help out with Coventry help
the coaching which I did and then when I
was fit to play I asked if I could go
online there and which happened so I
played for a bit and then they um
um they offered me a well asked me to
come back permanently the next year but
I I mean that was it wasn't enough to
live on then it was only part-time
um so I said they needed it I needed a
job so they hooked me out with a job
which is um what I'm doing now actually
so I've been there yeah we'll set six
seven six eight eight years now maybe
um
so
um yes I do account management for for a
security fit so but I mean I got sort of
lumped into a role with work which I
didn't even have Bloody clue what I was
doing
um found it really tough and um but I
was lucky I had a good boss sort of
looked after me but it again it sort of
felt like all back you know bringing
back my Rugby days when you first get
picked into a team you don't think you
deserve there you think you know
everyone's looking at you because you're
not pulling your weight and all those
sort of um feelings came rushing back
but and and you're earning friggin a
quarter half or a third of what you were
earning as well
um you know in my last year
at tigers and and it's just awful now I
did I I really battle mate to be honest
I went through depression and all I did
I've done I've done what probably a lot
of ex-players have gone through have
done the gone through the depression
gone through the divorce
um gone through all that and um come out
the other side but it's been
um yeah those that was that year was
tough I was trying to sell a house in
New Zealand and you know the marriage
was on on the Rocks um our Coventry team
wasn't doing as well as what it should
have
um work was struggling and it was just
yeah I was just it got too much for me
got too much for me I remember
um yeah about I don't know about two or
three months in it was a it was a Monday
and I just wanted
broke down broke down in the office in
an office luckily it was behind closed
doors but I remember having a good old
good old week which I never do and um
called my boss and he was really good
about it and he said right here
um he said I said he goes write
everything down that's troubling you and
I'll give you a call back in an hour
we'll go through it and I did it all and
I read it all out to him and he goes I
don't think I don't know about you that
doesn't sound as bad as what I think it
is and he goes yeah I said yeah you're
probably right and but he was really
good he was quite um took some time he
knew because I was trying hard out I was
trying my best but I just felt you know
useless and then but again like like
anything you get into it for three
months four five six months and it
becomes a norm you become used to
everything you need to be done and then
you know a couple of years later I was
mentoring and another young fellow who
started you know in a similar position
to me so it all it was let's say it was
a few steps backwards to to take some
food I'm certainly a lot better for it
because you live in your as you know you
live in your rugby bubble for quite some
time you're earning good money you just
need to look after yourself long as you
as long as you're relatively fit injury
wise and you're playing all right things
are going to work for you but um you
once hit the big bad world it's a it was
a bit different it was a bit harder and
um yeah just all got all got a bit much
but uh but yeah I ended up at 12 and
then once so covered doing quite well
now so they they wanted a full-time guy
to take over and they did that which was
the right thing to do and it's proven
but he wanted to clear out so he got rid
of all the coaching stuff and most of
the players so
um that took me to Hinckley which was
where I went to play a coach so I said
as I said I was still playing at Cove
and then I was player player coach at
Hinckley for a while
um and yeah enjoyed that was level four
over here good good crack great Club
real good club um really enjoyed it and
then I ended up being director of rugby
there for a couple of seasons and I just
stepped down at the back end of last
year because um
yeah again I was just not not enjoying
it as much it's just hard to fit hard to
fit kids Work Director rugby and then I
mean I was single at the time when I
started and it was all right then I you
know I started seeing a girl now so just
trying to fit all that in is is tough
um so I decided to to pull it away and
how long was that process from when you
finished rugby
um that battle that you struggled with
how long was that whole process
um I would suggest I I finished you know
the season I mean I was injured I didn't
play so but I was playing cough so that
would have that would have been end of
May when the season finishes over here
and then I think I started my job and
August so you're probably looking August
September October probably the start's
always all right but probably September
October with my darkest darkest time
um yeah I made I just wanted to be a
postman or something I was just like
this is crap but
um you know I'm I'm you know as I said
I've always been that I've always sort
of been quite negative towards myself
and always felt that I was struggling
and didn't really matter what level I
was at I was always been quite
self-critical but um you know I know a
lot of people a lot of people are like
that
um but yeah like I said it's
at my worst mate at my worst I wish I'd
never played rugby because I blame rugby
for feeling how I was because I was like
if if I was used to a normal life I
wouldn't be feeling like this right now
and I would have given it away
everything I would have given away
everything which is looking back it's
just bizarre that you but it's amazing
how your brain works and how your mind
works and gets you and gets you in
States
um you know and when I think back now if
I'd get you know to give up my Rugby
that just you know it's been my life
even even now like just seeing people
and I play veterans rugby every now and
again and yeah all the all the good fun
and stuff it's given me but it's yeah
that that period there I would have
given it all away
um but yeah like I said
came out come out the other side so it's
um bigger and stronger I suppose so it's
all it's all good right that's crazy to
him what was that what was those lowest
points like we uh did you turn to the
booze or what what did it look like how
did you really know that you were
struggling so bad yeah I mean the booze
was all I mean it's always been there
for me I would say I haven't handled it
the best in my life
um it's certainly got a lot better of
late but I I I always found it as a good
release I always found
um like I said I didn't have a lot of
confidence never really did but
obviously after a few Scoops you're full
of confidence and you get
I certainly get a you know a couple of
bowls of loud mouth soup down me and
people can hear me from anywhere so I
did certainly use it as a um as a
release
um but it
yeah I mean there's yeah there are
plenty of plenty plenty of nights that
you look back in and check your head and
wonder what the hell you're doing
um but again that that sort of relates
back to
um not just uh work but you know
relationship troubles and all that stuff
you just want to get away and um yeah I
mean I hear lots of people talk about it
and it is
and if like now because I've been
through the crap
um what I find is the best for me now
whilst you don't get me wrong I love a
beer still but it's exercise
um now because I'm not doing any rugby
or anything like that you know if I
don't go to the gym or go for a run or
something if I spend a week or 10 days
doing nothing and then I have a [ __ ] day
it really it really makes me feel worse
but if I get out and go for a run it
really helps me just exercise helps and
that's why I love you know I try and
play like when I finished I was always a
Vex rugby you know what would you want
to play that but you know awesome and
you meet so many leads you know some X
Pros or some just X players just just
good lads that you can have a beer with
and I do Amsterdam tournament every year
just did that
um early early June this year that's
awesome you know you go over there play
some vets for the you get pissed at the
night
you roll out of bed go again try try and
win the Tron went on Final stay and then
have a big night and then fly over fly
out and go home again and that you mean
I've I've met so many mates through
there and that actually the Vets rugby
was something that really helped me
because that was when I was really
struggling
um you know with the with the um you
know the divorce and all that sort of
crap and I was sort of again you know I
was sitting on the couch and didn't want
to go to the pub and didn't want to do
anything didn't want to see mates just
wanted to watch TV just wanted to be by
myself and it wasn't really until I I
went to this vets I didn't know I didn't
know a soul just just meeting people was
there for like three nights had awesome
trip and then you know still on a
WhatsApp group you know and you jump
around if you're in different if
someone's in this neighborhood or you're
up there you you know you catch up you
say hello and it's you know Rugby's such
an awesome uh you know where networking
and just just catching up it's awesome
so it was yeah rugby I can't get enough
I mean not just rugby I suppose any team
sports the same but you know I think
it's massive it's um Rugby's been bloody
also can't can't uh can't think it
enough right it's so cool and so so
powerful to hear you um speak about that
because I know how common that is
um that post rugby depression and uh
that transition is so hard for so many
players so I'm sure so many people find
that very beneficial to hear but as
always we've gone to our Instagram for
some questions and I mean a lot of these
have come in from noobs and a lot of
other followers from around the world
but uh we'll try and race through a few
of these
um to finish uh first question is
obviously a lot more about the nickname
bubbles we've covered that but the next
one what is your best jug scale time
you must go pretty quick do you oh mate
no I struggle I struggle I am good up to
about a seven seven ounce maybe a 12 if
you're lucky anything more than that
then I'm a real battler or I remember
him I've never timed I'd never be good
mate I my big concern is if I get
getting something like that is to set it
aside it needs to be relatively close to
warm temperature because I I struggle
struggle with the the coldness that's
why actually if you're going to give me
something give me a Guinness because
then I know I can um I can get through
that without getting a bloody headache
or something no I'm not I'm not a jack
skeller I'll finish it don't get me
wrong I'll you know slow instead he wins
the race I'll get there but I'm not I'm
not sitting anybody's land speed records
oh it's good stuff okay next one is
sleeping on artificial grass comfortable
apparently there's a few photos to prove
this
artificial no I think there was just
grass actually it was grass yeah well it
depends on the show I'm trying to that's
the least that's the incident that I
remember I can't remember them all but
uh I I think sleeping is comfortable
wherever you get because as we all know
sleeping is the best form of recovery
um and so wherever you can get it you
get it that's sort of my motto I'm
certainly in my old age I'm prone to
having a little nap in the in the corner
of a pub um uh if uh just sorted to give
myself a little 15 minute pound that
um I'm a big advocate for that still do
it um and the way I also said if you're
sleeping you can't cause any trouble
oh I like that's probably good advice
for
um some of the listeners out there okay
next one um tell us the story from the
Amsterdam tens no phone no wallet in a
bush yeah so that was my second trip to
Amsterdam so I I I'm not sure what
happened to be honest we had a massive
night and I'm I'm dressed up as uh Goose
from Top Gun
so I got the old because it was fancy
dress every the last night's always
fancy dress
and I I literally wake up walking down
the street if you know I mean my first
memory is walking down a street and I'm
like Jesus what the hell's going on I've
got no wallet no phone thinking okay so
I know where I'm staying so I get in a
managed to get a taxi he um he takes me
back to uh hotel I have to wake up my
roommate to get him to pay the taxi
driver
and bearing in mind I'm leaving that day
and I'm like I've got no phone no well
I'm like radio so I get someone's
finding my iPhone and then that that
shows like some grassy area just out of
town so clearly I've taken my love of
sleep into this grassy area I assume at
least someone's pickpocketed me and
thrown it out or something anyway so I
get a taxi there to try and thinking if
I can find my phone or form a wallet
anyway searching around searching around
searching around can't bloody find it oh
[ __ ] and then I'm like right I've got to
catch my flight and so I go back to the
room pack everything up get to the
airport and then realize I've left my
passport in the hotel safe ah gotta head
back again
get the thing and then I get back to the
airport and now I'm like gonna be late
and the lady tells me yep you need to go
down this end of the airport and I Rush
down there and look around I might I
can't see where I meant to be and then I
ask someone else and I've been given
wrong advice I'm down the other end of
the airport so anyway I missed my flight
I missed my flight I'm now in Amsterdam
airport with a passport and that's all
I've got obviously my cat but my
passports I've got no wallet no phone
um and no way of getting home obviously
because none of my teammates all they've
they're not at the airport I don't even
know you know who's there and who's
around and I've got no contacts
whatsoever and I'm thinking radio and
I'm bearing in mind hangover so I'm not
really I don't think so I sort of take
myself somewhere I sit down I think
right what are you going to do here
Scott you've got it and I said right
well you need some money so I went to
ask can I buy a ticket yeah you can buy
a ticket what's it worth 200 Euros okay
okay so then I went to Burger King and
there they some young English leads
there and I was just sort of trying to
find someone and I said I see right here
fellas um I've got a predicament told
them the story I said I need to borrow
200 Euros
um I will transfer the money if you give
me a phone I'll transfer your money call
the bank blah blah blah and they looked
at me suspiciously as you would
um and then one of them goes okay mate
I'll help you out because I'd like to
think someone would help me out if I was
in your situation I see bloody good
blokes I gave them I gave them an extra
20 euros to pay for his buddy Burger
King
anyway I got my money brought my ticket
and got home so I was quite proud of
myself to be able to actually uh make my
way back to uh get my back into the way
back into the UK
um a bit like The Amazing Race To be
honest mate I felt I felt quite quite
sure for myself when I got home did you
ever find your wallet or phone no no
I've been through a few wallets and
phones so that's that that's actually a
probably a really good barometer of
where you are uh there's a where you are
personally is how many wallets and
phones you've been through of late so to
be honest I I went through a lot through
that period that we just spoke about but
I don't think I've lost a wallet or a
phone for about five years so I think
that shows them in a much better place
than what I used to be used to be
probably an annual occurrence oh it's
good stuff okay next question uh there's
questions from our major sponsor swish
if you could get a video shout out from
any celebrity who would it be and why oh
a video shout out
oh good question
I would take someone probably funny man
I'd like some someone like Will Ferrell
or something like that I was thinking I
don't really care about Sportsman too
much it would be it'd be someone someone
funny like that that'd probably be where
I'd go you know I do enjoy him mate Will
Ferrell absolutely okay next one fastest
white dude you've ever played with this
guy said you were a white lightning
fastest white girl I thought they were
fast it's a set of any survivatu was
unbelievable I remember I played an all
black troll again I know he's not white
clearly but I remember coming in I was
at 15 or a wing I can't remember but he
broke the line and he just came up
squared me up and then took me on the
outside and I remember just doing the
token I'm going for your ankle tip but
knowing that I was nowhere near you know
it wasn't even near him I just remember
that day thinking Jesus you know I am
I'm way off the pace way off the pace
fastest white dude I always used to have
some big old battles with old Tim Tim
Nicholson the old uh sevens player when
he was at waikato he was a big white
fella like me so I used to remember and
then my other my other sort of was Petey
Hewitt my my Nemesis um he was at the he
was at New South Wales waratahs for a
while and they actually came over here
he played for London Iris I played him
over here a couple of times but I used
to always used to see him as my Nemesis
just because he has another white Winger
but actually when I got to meet him he
was a bloody good bloke but um yeah now
the other one Brent Ward I remember when
he um bring water as a bloody good lead
um played against him and with him yeah
I lived with the Maxi for a bit of time
when he came down the Crusaders here's
another another uh white outside back
there's not many of us mate not many of
us kicking around in New Zealand Rugby
but you just named all the white petlers
how good was that
laughs
oh good stuff okay uh next question what
do you remember about the cassavan
concert
not much to be honest with you that was
again uh I'd say that's in my tough time
I I thought it'd be a really good idea
to sneak a um uh vodka in in my one
liter water bottle
and then uh obviously got over excited
and ended up having a nap in the middle
of
um well not in the middle of it sort of
out the back somewhere but um
um yeah someone I came to in the uh some
John's ambulance but again it was a it
was a another one of my low times James
mate I'm not gonna lie um there was
probably there'd be a top
it could be a top three I think low
moment for me that one that one so I
prefer not to talk about it
is that true is it true a fan took a
photo of you
blackmail with you to put it on Twitter
or something yeah somebody's somebody
said I can't remember what the question
was somebody said something about all
right well on Twitter or something and
said Scott where are you and then he
took a picture I found him and took a
picture of me on the ground and then I
was like oh and then the next day I
contacted him I said listen mate I know
it's a laugh but I would appreciate you
taking it down it's not really going to
do I said I know it's all my fault blah
blah blah blah I wasn't aggressive about
or anything because obviously it's my
fault but I said can you take it down
mate because um any to be fair to me did
so um I've got no idea who it was but
yeah it wasn't as I said not my not my
finest um I was going to say not my
finest hour but probably not my finest
two or three years
but you kept your phone and wallet
didn't lose those uh yeah yeah I believe
so I believe so I've done it I didn't
yeah I don't know it was more yeah it
was yeah it's um it was one of those
ones that you you I mean even still like
to be honest now because kasabian's a
big list of band and it's massive but I
can't I cannot like any of these songs
simply because of that incident because
it just reminds me and I feel you know
just you just get that cringe feeling of
um every now and again yeah you'll just
be in a car somewhere and it comes on
you're going on and that's all I think
of which is you know again not the uh
not the best but um
yeah such as life we all make mistakes
oh there we are it's classic okay next
one this one's post LV cut final vs
Northampton apparently you've got a Land
Rover testing the next day talk me
through this one
um so we won the LV cap final
um and I had a bit of blue with the The
Wharf at the time and um
I ended up not being allowed in so
crashed around at the old mate said news
had just been through a
um he he went through his probably about
two years before I did maybe a bit
longer but um but anyway so I crashed at
news's place and because
I woke up and we had to be at this Land
Rover thing the next day and it was a
team building because it was so the LV
Cup Final for so it's um
it's like the third
best thing you can win and it happened
the final was
um sort of towards the back end of the
season so we still had plenty of rugby
left so it wasn't like it's the final
and you're on it and you're done but we
had a big night at the local pub and the
crested news place and then we um
where Atlanta and obviously we're all in
our number ones because that's what
we're wearing and I had nothing else to
wear so I I work up a minute One news
was like come on we got to go yeah I
didn't really want to go home so I was
like okay so we um we
um I just turned up to the Chica Land
Rover testing at 10 o'clock uh with my
number ones on and um everyone else has
obviously been changed yet and whatever
everyone's looking at me what the hell
are you doing I'm like wow long story
but in short I don't have any other
clothes to wear I don't know where I
didn't borrow something new just to be
honest but I hadn't obviously clearly
wasn't thinking the the quickest
um and and everyone else was driving and
I just sat in the back and they were
like do I drive and I'm like now mate
I'm all good I'm all good back here you
can just and it was like one of those
slow things up and down and going all
over the place and there was also a clay
pigeon shoot and things like that so we
did all that but
um so yeah it was I'll tell you it was a
good was well up until uh up until the
the obligatory
um argument after or not on the booze it
was a good night it was an awesome game
you know I scored a try on the final so
I'd love to but I'll just uh yeah again
probably uh one too many points proved
my undoing
uh good stuff okay two more two more
questions
um tell us about the all-inclusive
holiday in Egypt with the missus don't
know this one
gee that's about see that's another one
in the top three actually so I ended up
I could have sworn like we had
all-inclusive and I was just sitting
there I hadn't actually had that much to
drink and it was early doors but then
for whatever reason I don't know if I
don't know what had happened but I don't
know if there was some sort of I don't
know I hate to say this because everyone
goes Spy Kids or something but I hadn't
had enough to worry it wasn't like I'd
been there all day you know we've been
out doing stuff but anyway oh yeah I
lost the guts and ended up um falling
asleep in the toilet for some reason
which again that's that's very unique to
me normally I find a nice bit of grass
or a sofa across something so I don't
know what the hell we'll hear from there
I still I still
yeah I'm still a bit dubious about that
one I know I know obviously I've got a
fair bit of uh incriminating evidence
and a bit of bad background but I don't
think that was a hundred percent I still
think there's something fishy on that
one but um yeah that didn't that didn't
uh obviously go down very well either
with um yeah it was uh it was a to be
honest though great outside of that
night great trip mate great trip fully
recommend it we went to charm old shake
and then we took a day trip saw the
pyramids and all that so that was a good
it was a good uh it was a good trip
outside of the um outside of that one
one night we're doing yeah I don't know
all inclusive as you see but it just uh
the wheels fell off very very quickly
unfortunately the problem the big
problem was I was telling a um English
Feller about how
um a lot of the boys in England like um
don't really give a crap about like
whatever they just sort of drinking it's
all about you know the rugby culture the
same as the rugby culture over here like
in New Zealand a lot of the partners
will get involved
um you know and that's how it is but in
England is like ah now it's boys boys
boys it's always Boys Boys Boys Boys
which I've always found it's a bit
awkward because it's just he's I mean
obviously you have some good thing about
New Zealand you have the old way trip
you can have it just the boys but when
you're at home you know the partners are
there and that was always how it was and
I think that's how it should be but um
um yeah and I was just saying how you
know I was sort of begging and begging
the people of the English and all that
and saying how they you know just did
whatever they want on the piss and then
I was the one um sleeping in the in the
toilet at the end of it so clearly I
didn't follow what I when I didn't
practice what I preached
we've got two of your top three worst
moments What's the other one well I've
got one actually I'm surprised this is
another so this is my first one so we we
um
um this is more humorous though so
whilst it is embarrassing at least it
ended at least it ended well
um so we had 2003 we had just lost to
the blues and um in the Super Rugby
final
and we flew back we're all headed into
Christchurch and
got on it hard and I um
um I've got a horrible tendency if I
can't wait for a taxi if there's nothing
there my mind is I'll find one and I
just go walking which is the stupidest
thing in the world because clearly you
want to stay in the most built up area
to get a taxi and I've done it plenty of
times because I just for every reason I
get in my mind that I'm going to solve
this issue anyway so I did that and I'm
walking down
um
um I can't like Manchester Street or
something heading out towards that way
and obviously I get halfway there and
all of a sudden I'm like I need to sleep
I'm done I can't find anything and
clearly what I've done is that there was
a girl someone had um walked and just
walked into a house and I've obviously
seen it and gone okay and I've got no
record Liquors with whatsoever so I
um uh I I'll go in the door and I she's
obviously gone to bed or whatever and
I've just gone to sleep on the couch in
the front front living room very similar
to what um who did it down in Queenstown
was it Xavier rush or Norm Hewitt or
someone did something like that they you
know they they were plastered all over
the herald you see so mine again mine
ended up quite nicely so again I've got
no idea obviously we'd all had a skin
full and then
the fella the sun comes down in the
morning and I'm done up I'm a crusader
number ones and he goes that wakes up
his old man and goes dead dead there's a
crusader on the couch and I'm like oh oh
it's a kid he's like what the hell when
he comes down anyway he calls someone
and our physio comes to get me and so
this must have been early like six or
something in the morning and again still
no recollection so I I wake up in my bed
thinking oh yeah I've made it home sweet
ass no troubles here we obviously start
having a few beers again
um because it's the end of the season
and the physio comes around and goes oh
he starts looking at me and I'm like
what are you talking about he goes what
do you mean he goes don't you remember
us you remember what he goes where'd you
wake up I said in my room he goes no you
didn't I said yeah I did anyway so he
tells me the whole story of what what
happened and I'm like oh [ __ ] oh awful
anyway so I'll get this guy's number and
he's um you know I'm obviously really
apologetic and I um I get him one of my
jerseys I get it signed and you know I
give him a tab vetting voucher I give
them quite a bit of stuff because
obviously it could have gone pear-shaped
I can't really yeah I gave him a you
know Mets Jersey to be a few other
things bottle of wine or some beers or
something so I took it around them I see
I'm so sorry and he goes he said yeah he
said it's all right he said to be honest
mate in all the houses and all across
this mine was probably a pretty good one
to come and see and I'm like yeah you
know because I mean imagine now as I
said I was Bloody lucky to be honest
that's been kept relatively quiet until
now probably but um like I said I don't
know who the gentleman was
um but bloody good bloke clearly and um
thank you very much
oh that is good stuff that guy he did
save it absolute lad that is a that is a
good play from him okay last question
best piece of advice you have for a
water lad listener you've given heaps
throughout this episode already looking
forward to this oh best piece of advice
um yeah look uh it depends but for me
and I always think it sort of depends on
what kind of person you are but you
gotta look after yourself first you've
got to be happy first
um for me and I've sort of taken a while
you you've obviously got lots of things
going in your life but unless you're
happy you're not going to make the
people around you happy and um and
obviously you know everything's
give and take and you've got to do
certain things and you've got to look
after yourself sometimes and and look
after other people but you know
certainly if you're going through some
shitty times you've got to look after
yourself you've got to work out what
makes you uh makes you happy and haven't
gone like I said I I I always was a bit
skeptical about depression really I mean
I knew it was there but I was like oh
you know just the normal kiwi bloke
attitude you just crack on you get over
it until until I went through it
um and then you know you realize I
suddenly realize now why people do what
they do
um and like I said it was a [ __ ] time
but
um you know I've come out a lot more
understanding of myself and of other
people I suppose so yeah don't make it
too bloody serious but I think you know
with all with all the [ __ ] that's going
on the world at the moment you look
after yourself
um back yourself
I think most people I would say freaking
90 of the population uh uh I think they
are not as good as what other people you
know what is good of what other people
probably perceive you to be because I
know myself you tend to focus on always
have focused on the [ __ ] you did wrong
and you need to
um you need to get better at rather than
the stuff that's really good I always
remember like Wayne Smith runs in the
All Blacks you know he's like um focus
on your strengths you don't you don't
just practice your weaknesses you want
to make your strength stronger as well
and I'd never really thought of that
because you always drilled into your you
know work on your weaknesses practice
your left foot do this do that whether
it's you know you there's always always
one thing I've always remember you know
always work on your strength thing it
same as in life you know
yeah you're most most people are good
bloats and you've got to make sure you
look after yourself look after yourself
mentally
and physically certainly I like I said
you know I like to I'm certainly never
been a gym but I never like to be overly
fit but I if I don't do exercise it
affects me mentally and it's it's messy
for me and I you know and the other
thing is you're a long time retired mate
so play for as long as you're bloody
walking
right right love that advice so much in
there there's everything in that advice
and so much on that podcast as well
obviously
um hell of a rugby Journey from the
third 15 to becoming an all-black water
pathway
um a little bit more serious stuff there
with the transition and obviously a hell
of a lot of diesel Yarns because it
sounds like you've had a hell of a time
on the pest with some of the lads over
your career but mate really appreciate
you coming on the podcast being awesome
to catch up with a fellow white battler
and
um obviously someone who I was called
the first few years of my career so it's
been awesome to have a yarn with you no
worries mate no much appreciate us on
yeah I'm heading back to Chris uh
heading back to New Zealand Christmas so
hopefully to catch up for anyone's
around like charging into Christchurch
for a couple of weeks so I'm looking
forward to that right and if anyone sees
you out in the town um offer them a
beard so he doesn't have to sleep on the
grass
yeah I like to think of a changed man
now mate you know I'm in my 40s here a
little bit more you know slightly more
mature
I appreciate it good man cheers buddy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]